متوفر الآن رضاء
100 إعلان مضمون يدعي بيع
19 لقاحًا أصليًا
تم العثور عليه على الويب المظلم يمكننا رؤيته هناك
بأكثر من ثلاثة أضعاف
اللقاحات المعروضة في ثلاثة
أشهر ، لذا
فإنه يتم باستمرار رفع
نقطة تفتيش شركة الأمن
السيبراني.  الإعلانات ذات الصلة على الويب المظلم
لأشهر ، لذا في البداية كانت
الأدوية هي كيفية معالجتها ، ثم
وجدنا اللقاحات ، ثم تضاعفت أكثر
فأكثر ، وما وجدناه لاحقًا هو
أنهم أصبحوا مهتمين أكثر بالمجتمع
بدأوا في فتح  ونتقدم للأمام ،
وجدنا اهتمامًا أكبر
بالقدرة على شراء الاختبارات السلبية
، والآن مع طرح اللقاحات ،
نجد
أيضًا جوازات سفر للقاحات ، لذلك هذا هو
السوق الذي
وجدته جيدًا في البداية ، نشاهد شركة
Moderna pfizer الأحدث
لدينا هنا جرعة واحدة من
جونسون وجونسون يمكننا أن نرى أن هذا مجرد
مثال على
نقطة تفتيش إعلانية حاولت شراء سينبا
لقاح ck على الويب المظلم مرة أخرى في كانون الثاني (يناير)
مقابل 750 من عملة البيتكوين ،
لم يصل أي شيء على الإطلاق ، ليس لدينا أي
دليل على
أن أي شخص قد اشترى بنجاح
وحصل على لقاح ، وإذا كان قد تم توصيل
هذه المنتجات لم تظهر فقط
على الإنترنت ، أصدر الإنتربول تنبيهًا عالميًا
أخيرًا  تحذير عام من
أن شبكات الجريمة المنظمة
ستستغل مجرمي الوباء
الذين يستغلون أي فرصة مع
هذه
الشهادات المزيفة المتعلقة بنسخة 19 من
التطعيم
أو الاختبار الذي رأيناه حتى في بعض
أنحاء العالم أن المجرمين
يقتربون جسديًا من الحدود
و  إنهم يقدمون هذا النوع من
الخدمات التي
تقدم للأشخاص الذين يرغبون بشدة في
عبور الحدود على سبيل المثال لرؤية أقاربهم
يزودونهم على الحدود بشهادة مزيفة
تتعلق بنتيجة اختبار سلبية أو
حتى تطعيم
الشهر الماضي حلقة توزيع لقاح مزيفة
تعمل عبر اثنين
تم تفكيك القارات مما أدى إلى اعتقال أكثر من 80
شخصًا
في كلا البلدين وكل هؤلاء
يمكن أن تؤخذ آلاف الجرعات من اللقاحات المزيفة من السوق
قبل أن
تلحق الضرر مرة أخرى بالناس تؤكد كل من الإنتربول
ونقاط التفتيش
أنه لا يمكنك شراء لقاح 19 سريًا
عبر الإنترنت ،
فقد لا تتلقى قنينة أبدًا وإذا
كنت لا تعرف
ما هو  إذا كان هناك شيء يبدو
جيدًا لدرجة يصعب تصديقه ، فمن المحتمل أن
يكون هذا هو ما تم افتراسه ، فأنت تعلم أن
هذا الشعور باليأس
هو سبب وجود هذا ولكن
نصيحتي 100 هي أنك تعلم
فقط أنه لن يحدث فقط آنا
ستيوارت  سي ان ان
لندن